hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
targeted profiling of critically ill
stars kobe 2 subjects
from transcriptome to prodium i am
michelle ashton of labruz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker doug
frazier
professor and clinician scientist at
western university
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
then after you now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction and i'd
like to start off by thanking thermal
fisher scientific for sponsoring this
webinar i have a
several conflict of interest statements
to begin with
i have three non-academic positions one
is chief medical officer of neurolytics
incorporated
in toronto canada i'm a scientific
consultant for diagnostics biochem
canada
in london canada and a product
consultant for thermo fisher scientific
from vienna austria i currently have
four provisional patents
related to covid19 and related to the
work i will show you today
back in march of this year we saw our
first
covet 19 patient here in london ontario
canada
we were well prepared both clinically
and from a research perspective
having spent many months speaking with
our colleagues overseas
we had designed a study and we're ready
to go at that point in time
any patients that were admitted to the
intensive care unit
for up for ventilation
or for increased monitoring that met
sepsis
3.0 criteria and a covid 19
clinical screen were recruited into our
study
we began taking blood work on admission
and then every day and by 24 hours
the nasopharyngeal swab for stars cov2
genes
were back if a patient was covid
19 negative we maintained blood work for
the first three days of admission
and if the patient was coven 19
positive we continued blood work for
days one through seven
and then every three days thereafter
until the patient
was discharged or died
our approach and our analysis are as
shown we used plasma for metabolomics
for proteomics for functional assays and
for serology while we saved the buffy
coat and that was used
for rna sequencing all of our data
was then analyzed using conventional
statistics
as well as machine learning which would
include dimensional
dimensionality reduction and
classification
to give you some idea of our covid19
patient
clinical and demographic data this would
be
a typical cohort that we would study
with our covid 19 positive patients
on the left covid 19 negative icu
patients in the middle
and healthy age and sex controls on the
right
the the patient cohorts were very well
matched with the exception
of the bmi which was greater in the
covet positive patients
the cova negative patients exhibited
higher
mod scores and sofa scores indicating
higher level of illnesses and more
organ dysfunction involved in their
disease processes
there were equal numbers of
comorbidities and the baseline
labs were similar
when it came to the pulmonary findings
the covid positive patients
were more likely to have bilateral
pneumonia and to have lower
pf ratios consistent with ards
all covet positive patients on day one
were confirmed
by pcr testing for sars cov2
and the cova negative patients four or
28 percent of patients had a confirmed
pathogen on icu day one
our interventions were similar with the
exception that high flow nasal cannula
was used
more frequently in the covid19 positive
patients
fifty percent of the covalent 19
patients survived
whereas 86 percent of the cova negative
patients survived
for our first study i'll talk about
transcriptional profiling of leukocytes
obtained from critically ill covin-19
patients
for this study all samples were
sequenced using
illumina next seek 500.
our gene-specific analysis yielded
three hundred and eleven differentially
expressed genes
principal principle component analysis
revealed clustering of samples
based on sars kobe two pcr status
and on the right-hand graph one can see
the covad 19 positive patients in red
tightly clustered
while the covalent coping negative
patients
were more dispersed likely secondary to
a greater range of pathologies
and infectious agents involved
we found that 1057 genes were down
regulated
while 254 genes were up regulated
in the covet positive group
further functional analysis revealed an
overall up regulation in
interfering mediated gene transcription
in leukocytes from the cova 19 positive
icu patients
whereas genes associated with protein
translation were all down regulated
in leukocytes of cova-19 positive
patients
functional enrichment analysis suggested
an overexpression of genes that
characterize cd14 positive monocytes
and cd33 positive myeloid cells in the
covid positive patients
suggesting amplified macrophage activity
a heat map is shown with the
differentially expressed genes
the top seven patients are covid
positive the bottom
seven patients are covet negative
our gene set enrichment analysis was
then used to identify differentially
expressed gene sets
in the entire data set after correcting
for multiple comparisons
our analysis revealed that 69 of gene
transcripts were negatively enriched or
decreased
while 31 were positively enriched or
increased in the coved uh
19 negative versus covet positive
icu patients respectively furthermore a
total of 7 out of 50 gene sets were
negatively enriched while
26 of 50 were positively enriched
in addition to over representation of
genes associated with interference
signaling
we identified enrichment for gene sets
involved in tnf and il6
signaling complement signaling apoptosis
and coagulation
pathways in contrast gene transcripts
contributing to metabolic pathways
involving protein synthesis
oxidative phosphorylation and dna repair
were consistently and markly down
regulated
we then performed network analysis to
visualize higher level
changes in biological organization this
approach identified tightly connected
nodes or clusters
indicating shared relationships between
differentially expressed genes
the top network clusters and key
biological processes
identified that were differentially
regulated in the covid
19 positive versus the covid 19 negative
icu patients
notable clusters and processes
identified by these analysis
included platelet activation with 20
gene sets
neurotrophin signaling with 29 gene sets
stimulation and ubiquination of proteins
with 27
gene sets and total receptor cascades
with 12
gene sets
in summary our transcriptional profiling
our sars cov2 infection elicit a unique
transcriptional profile sars cov2
infection is associated with multiple
interrelated outcomes including enhanced
interference signaling
dysregulated protein synthesis and
increased platelet
activation and coagulation stars cov2
infected subjects
exhibited robust transcriptional
elevations and sepsis related genes
including
tnf granzyme b and syndican1
i'll move on now to our metabolomics
profiling
in this particular set of experiments we
use two techniques we use direct
injection
lc tandem mass spec and nmr
to look at over 200 plasma metabolites
from our patient cohorts
in this first series of graphs the
in a we show what is a tsne plot
or a dimensionality reduction technique
where we are comparing the metabolite
profiles the complete
metabolite profiles between healthy
controls and covid
19 positive icu patients one can see a
complete separation
in their metabolomic profile with a
classification accuracy of 100 percent
our feature ranking suggested fairly
equal
uh importance across a number
of different metabolites in particular
kinderinine
arginine sarcosine and a number of
lysophosphatidylcholines
kineranine is liberated from tryptophan
uh metaboli metabolization and it is the
first stable intermediate to be formed
in increased degradation of tryptophan
uh with a consequential increase in
kanarin occurs
during the immune response and is driven
by the release of interfering gamma
from activated t cells arginine an amino
acid precursor for nitric oxide
oxide was significantly depressed in our
covalent positive patients
the arginine depletion is likely
secondary the intense requirement for
nitric oxide signaling
and antiviral activity as well as
consumption by the enzyme arginase 1
that represents a macrophage
immunoregulatory mechanism as arginine
is essential for tissue repairs
depletion could potentially delay
and or compromise icu recovery
sarcocine enhances the activity of
antigen presenting cells
and activates the tough autophagy or the
body's removal of
damaged cells in their immuno modulatory
debris
as a protective catabolic process during
coping 19
autophagy is critical to the antiviral
response
by direct elimination of virus the
presentation of viral antigens
and the inhibition of excessive
inflammation
sarcocene levels decrease with age and
the elderly are most susceptible to
copin 19
morbidity and mortality
the lyso phosphatidylcholines were
depressed
in the covalent 19 patients and they are
important for endothelial activation and
phagocytosis of cellular debris
the decreased lysopcs has been observed
previously in sepsis
and may it may aid pathogen elimination
and therapeutic
replacement of them has been suggested
to improve septic
sepsis outcome you'll notice in our
final graph
a rock curve that we have an area under
the curve of 1.0
or a perfect predictive value
of using a ratio of arginine to
kinerinine
for identifying covid19 patients
relative to healthy controls
we now compare cobit-positive to
cova-negative
icu patients and we have a slightly
different
ranking of importance with the get with
the metabolites that were measured
however kineranine still remain number
one
if we take the arginine kinetone ratio
again
we get an area under the curve of 0.98
for differentiating covid positive
versus covalent negative icu patients
and finally in our last graph we show a
time plot over 10 icu days
where the ratio of arginine to
chenorenine is most
important for identifying the covit 19
positive patients
and it is distinct from covalent
negative patients and and healthy
control range
next we took our covid positive
cova 19 positive patients and looked at
their outcome
being either alive or dead and we
compared the metabolomic response again
with creatinine being the most important
molecule
the creatinine arginine ratio predicted
those patients had died with 100
certainty and a time course is shown
in the lower graph
the angiotensin converting enzyme 2
receptor that is essential for sars cov2
uptake is highly expressed on tubule
epithelial cells an acute kidney injury
is reported to occur in up to 37 percent
of the covalent 19 patients
and his secondary acute tubular injury
from direct viral infection
i'll summarize our metabolomics
profiling by saying that sars
cov2 infection elicits a unique profile
that arginine countering ratio
accurately identify
sars kobe 2 infect infection status
whereas creatinine arginine ratio
actually predicted sars
cov2 associated death i'd suggest that
administration of tryptophan
the kinderine precursor arginine sarco
sarcocene and or lyso
phosphatidylcholines
may be considered potential therapies
for covid19 our studies also raise the
possibility of using
measurements of these three metabolites
for point-of-care diagnostics we are
currently investigating
these molecules earlier on in the
disease process
i'll move on now to inflammation
profiling of the critically ill
chronovirus disease patients and in this
particular set of experiments we use
multiplex on a luminex platform
we analyzed over 70
immune and inflammatory molecules and
those that are positive
are demonstrated in this in this table
you'll notice that a wide variety of
molecules from enzymes
to cytokines to chemokines are all
elevated
between healthy controls and covalent 19
positive patients
the common molecules such as tnf
il-6 and il-8 are all present
when we compare the inflammatory immune
profile
between covet-positive icu patients and
cova-negative icu patients
we are able to separate out the groups
on icu days
one through three with a classification
accuracy of 98 percent
the feature ranking is shown on the
right hand side
you'll notice that tnf is the single
most
important molecule or or
analyte for the separation between covet
positive
and cova negative icu patients you'll
also notice that il-6 does not exist on
this list
il-6 was in fact the same between the
two patient populations
and in fact il-6 targeting
in sepsis patients previously has failed
you'll notice that there are two
proteins serine proteases that are also
in the top six granzyme b which is
uh contained within lymphocytes and
elastate two which is contained within
neutrophils
post-mortem examination of covid19
patients
has shown that there is an early influx
of cytotoxic lymphocytes into the
pulmonary tissue
and these these lymphocytes contain
granzyme b
followed by a secondary neutrophil
infiltration with cells that contain
elastase ii
when we looked at the top six molecules
over time
over seven icu days we showed the
the concentrations of the molecules for
the covid
positive patients and the covalent
negative patients
and you will see that tnf has a tenfold
increase
in plasma concentration which is
persistent
over all seven days of icu stay
this is important observation because
tnf
which is the gatekeeper pro-inflammatory
cytokine
has been shown in other sepsis studies
to go up quickly
and come down quickly often within hours
anti-tnf
therapy in previous sepsis trials
has failed and it is largely thought
that that failure is because
the cytokine is up down and by the end
gone by the time
we are treating these patients in
contrast covet 19 positive icu patients
have quite a dramatic elevation and it
is persistent
tnf has macrophage expression and is
involved in immune regulation
granzyme b as i stated earlier
is is contained within lymphocytes and
macrophages and it is the apoptosis
mediator
is also has powerful enzymatic
properties over numerous proteins
hsp 70 or heat shock protein 70
has wide expression and is induced by
stress
generally thought to be protective il-18
has macrophage endothelial expression
and induces interfering gammon
ip10 has monocyte endothelial expression
is a chemoattractant and elastase ii as
previously discussed
is contained within neutrophils and it
hydrolyzes proteins
you'll notice that all of these
molecules are elevated
over seven days of stay
elastase 2 climbs with time
i'll end this series of experiments by
with the summary that sars kovi 2
infection elicits a unique immune
inflammatory profile
that the top six analytes distinguishing
sars kobe 2 infected patients from non
sars kobe 2 icu patients were tnf
renzyme b hsp70
il-18 ip10 and elastase 2.
therapeutic targeting of tnf and or
serine proteases
may improve sars cov2 outcomes
in our study elevated heat shock protein
70
was strongly associated with sars kobe 2
mortality
i've added an additional reference at
the bottom our
our general premise is that our
anti-cytokine therapies
for cova 19 should be informed by
detailed
inflammatory profiling and specific
therapeutic targets
we should not be basing our therapies on
single time points
or on patients which are not well
matched
i'm going to move on now to another set
of experiments
novel outcome biomarkers that were
identified with targeted proteomic
analyses
in this particular study we used
proximal extension
assay it's provided by o-link
and used very similar approaches to the
last study
on on the left-hand side you'll see a
tsne plot
where healthy controls are compared to
cova 19
positive icu patients based on the
proteomic
profiling you'll notice the
classification accuracy of 100 percent
the relative importance of individual
proteins
is shown at the on the right hand side
and involves a number of different
molecules including interleukins
cytokines chemokines etc
we also compared the proteomics pro
profiles from covet positive patients to
covet negative patients
on icu day one and also had a
classification accuracy
of 100 percent once again
the proteins and their relative
importance is shown on the right hand
side
and there's a wide range of proteins
listed we also looked at those patients
that died
versus those patients that survived both
on icu day one
and then on end on icu day three
the patients that died in red show
clustering
and a classification accuracy of 92
percent on icu day one
that decreased to 83 percent on icu day
three
you'll notice that the proteins and the
relative importance are shown
and there are similarities between the
two lists for example clm-1
which is number three making up five
percent of the difference
between patients that lived or died on
icu day one
is also protein number two on icu day
three
we did feature reduction to see which
proteins were most important for
determining
or for predicting which patients would
be
alive or dead on their icu stay
and we found the top six proteins
determined
a patient's outcome very well on icu day
one
with a complete separation dlm1
is expressed in macrophages and it
promotes phagocytosis
cleaning up debris and other
inflammatory molecules in the system
you'll notice in the graph with clm-1
that the bottom line uh only goes to day
seven that's because
that patient that survived was actually
discharged from the icu on day seven
and it is the house that patient had the
lowest concentration of clm-1
patients that died are in red patients
that survive during green and there's a
complete separation across
10 icu days other molecules that were
important for determining covalent 19
outcome
include il12rb1
which is lymphocyte expressed and it's
pro-inflammatory
cd83 which has wide expression and is
immuno
it has immunosuppression properties bam
38
has pancreatic expression and induces
apoptosis
igf-1r has lymphocyte macrophage
expression
is involved with target cell
proliferation and cytokine production
and optc or up ptosin opticin
is in expressed lymphocytes and inhibits
endothelial
invasion when i look at clm-1
i see a pattern in icu day 1 with
complete separation
we are now investigating whether these
molecules can determine who will have a
poor outcome
earlier on in their eyes earlier on in
their in their illness
perhaps when they first arrive in the
emergency room when they're in hospital
or perhaps when they first develop
symptoms
these types of outcome studies are very
important outcome biomarkers
will serve three important functions
first they will tell you when you need
to
to mobilize resources two
they'll allow you to have very frank and
honest conversations with caregivers and
patients
about what their wishes are in terms of
care and
three they're important for patient
stratification in clinical studies
i'll summarize this set of experiments
with stars cov2 infection elicits a
unique proteomic profile
dominated by interleukins cxcls
chemokines
membrane receptors linked to lymphocyte
associated microparticles and or
cellular debris pattern recognition
receptors
cytoplasmic cytoskeletal proteins and
nuclear proteins and transcription
factors
all of these are listed in the
supplementary data
in our paper that has been published
furthermore multiple proteins were
identified that accurately predicted
stars kobe 2 associated
mortality three the identification of
sars kobe 2
outcome biomarkers may be invaluable for
guiding resource mobilization
goals of care discussion and patient
stratification
i'll move on now to our studies on
endothelial
injury and glycocalyx degradation which
are important for thrombus
formation it did not take too long in
working with
covid positive patients to observe that
they had
a very high risk of developing thrombi
we we measured a number of thrombosis
factors as well as endothelial
activation markers and glycocalyx
degradation products between healthy
control subjects and coronavirus
positive patients in the intensive care
unit we looked
at three molecules that are important
for thrombosis
including including atom ts13 protein c
and von willebrand factor
in other forms of sepsis atom
atom ts13 and protein c are both
greatly reduced well von willebrand
factor
tends to be quite high
activated protein c is a key
anticoagulant and it serves
physiologically relevant it's a
physiologically relevant modulator of
the inflammatory response
atom ts-13 is essential for cleaving von
willebrand factor
which is a large multimeric glycoprotein
that mediates platelet adhesion to the
endothelium
in our studies von willebrand factor as
expected was greatly elevated
however we were unable to arrive at
statistical significance
for protein c or atom ts 13.
von willebrand factor is elevated by
inflammation as well as endothelial
injury and activation
we took these molecules the measurements
of these molecules as well as
measurements of platelet
activation and endothelial injury and
we profiled these the the complete set
of
measurements uh to determine uh which
to determine if we could deter to see if
we could determine which patients fell
into which
care which category the
classification accuracy between healthy
subjects and copin 19 positive patients
was 85 percent and it was 85 percent
between
coven 19 positive and covid 19 negative
patients
we then did feature ranking and we found
that the three most important molecules
that for determining which patients
would have thrombosis
where p-selectin soluble piece lectin
which is has a platelet and endothelial
expression and is involved in cell
adhesion
inflammation and coagulation hyaluronic
acid
a member of the glycocalyx or hair-like
structures which line the
microvasculature
has in this molecule as endothelial
expression it is a disaccharide polymer
and then cinder can one which also has
endothelial expression is a proteoglycan
and also part of the glycocalyx
you will notice on day three that
hyaluronic acid is the
most significantly elevated of the three
we therefore did functional experiments
with human pulmonary microvascular
endothelial cells
that we had obtained previously from
patients
and we expose those cells to
hyaluronidase to remove the hyaluronic
acid
removal of hyaluronidase resulted in a
98
reduction in nitric oxide production
endothelial nitric oxide is important
to reduce platelet adhesion
our studies suggest that coven 19 blood
vessels
have decreased glycocalyx
decrease nitric oxide production
increased von willebrand factor and
platelet adhesion
this data has led us to suggest in the
literature
that standard anticoagulation therapy
may not be the way to go but platelet
inhibitors
or protection of the endothelium
the endothelial glycocalyx may in fact
yield better results
i'm going to speak briefly about a
pediatric patient we saw
with myth c or the multi-inflammatory
syndrome related to covid19
we had a 15 year old girl who showed up
to our emergency room with a kawasaki's
like
presentation including high fever a
strawberry tongue gi
symptoms and a slightly high bilirubin
this particular patient was positive on
on pcr for sars cov2
we took blood and did similar
uh experiments to what we have done
previously measuring inflammatory and
immune markers
and we compared this patient to 20
healthy subjects
to which we also took blood and
characterized in the same way
you will notice on this tsne plot that
the profile of the patient with
miss c was very different than healthy
controls
when we feature rank the molecules we
found that there is
increased enzymes in particular matrix
metalloproteinases
mmp7 and mmp8 as well as
elastase 2 from neutrophils
we also found an increase in hyaluronic
acid and heparin sulfate two
markers of glycocalyx degradation
and p-selectin this data fits
very closely with what one would see in
a kawasaki's like syndrome
and may explain why the two phenomena
are quite similar
we also assayed the serological
responses
in our our critically ill cova 19
patients
in this particular case we used elisa
kits
from diagnostics biochem canada
which are health canada approved and
available in canada
europe and south america
using three kits which are were specific
to igg
iga and igm and then bringing the
results together
we looked at the complete antibody resp
response between cobit positive and
covalent negative patients
by icu day seven there is a one hundred
percent
separation which continued for the rest
of the icu stay
prior to that on icu day three the
classification accuracy was 96 percent
and 89 in icu day one
when we looked at the individual
responses the individual antibody
responses
we found it at a pattern that would be
expected
in that igm was elevated by about icu
day
12. iga was maximally elevated by but
icu day 18 and igg
elevated and stayed elevated throughout
the icu stay
which for the one patient was as long as
40 days
a total antibody response an elisa kit
which has antibodies to all three of the
immunoglobulins
displayed also a suspected response
when we compared patients that survived
their icu stay versus those
that did not we found very similar
responses
and in fact our statistical analysis
tells us that the iga response and total
antibody response
may in fact have occurred with
more robustly in those patients that
passed away
when we started these experiments we
hypothesized that patients that passed
away
may not be developing a strong
serological response
but in fact it was the exact opposite
this may represent the fact that those
patients
that died had a bigger viral load to
begin with
but actually had the appropriate
serological response
i'll summarize those experiments by
saying critically ill patients exhibit
robust
anti-sars cov2 serological responses
including those
that ultimately died total ig assay was
the most useful for classifying star's
cov2 status early after icu admission
stars cov2 patients who died exhibited
earlier iga and total igp
ig peaks suggesting that blunted
serological responses
did not contribute to mortality i'll
also be provocative
by stating that treatment of active
coping 19 disease with convalescent
plasma
may be redundant given that given the
robust serological response measured
in all of the stars cov2 icu patients
and in fact as we were doing these
experiments a randomized control
trial from the netherlands was stopped
early
because there was no improvement with
convalescent
plasma therapy and the patients in that
study
also developed quite robust intrinsic
responses
next we'll discuss detection of human
coronavirus immunoglobulin subtypes in
critically ill patients
using a multiplex procedure on a luminex
platform
with thermal fissure scientific
in this set of experiments we looked at
igg
10 10 subtypes of igg from different
human coronaviruses the top four are all
specific for sars cov2
whereas the bottom six are not you will
see in this data
with this data that the covet positive
patients
developed robust responses to all
kovi sarsko v2 igg
and while sars kovi s1 protein
was elevated it was a mild elevation
with a
an easy cutoff value
when we used all the stars cov2
measurements together on our patients
and
looked at their total response on icu
day one we had a classification accuracy
between
healthy controls and coven 19 positive
patients of 82
the the serological response increased
to
and the classification accuracy
increased to 93
by icu day 2 and by icu day 3
the igg response was maximal and it
stayed at 100
classification accuracy thereon when we
looked at the
feature ranking of which igg was most
important for the separation
there were three that were equal that
included the s1 protein
the receptor binding domain and the
spike protein the nucleocapsid protein
was less effective when we compared
covid positive to covet
19 negative icu patients on icu day one
the classification accuracy was 86
on icu day two the classification
actually was eighty-nine percent
and it increased to ninety-nine percent
on icu day three
and was stable thereon again the feature
ranking
demonstrated a similar pattern where the
s1 protein the spike protein and the
receptor binding domain
protein were all equally important for
this separation between groups
we now show a timed course for these
iggs
and permea and the cova 19 positive
patients increased
with time with 100 separation again on
day three
from cova negative and healthy control
patients
and the the increase was persistent
with slightly more variability with the
nucleocapsid protein
we did rock curve analyses on icu day 3
and we found an area under the curve for
the s1 protein of 1.0
or excellent sensitivity and specificity
when we compared covalent positive
patients to healthy control as well as
to
cova-positive patients to cover negative
patients
auc remained 1.0 for both comparisons
with the spike protein
and it also remained 1.0 for the
receptor binding domain
with healthy control comparison to covet
positive
patients the covid positive coping
negative patients
with the rbd protein decreased slightly
with an auc of 0.93
the nico capsid protein had an area
under the curve of 0.95
and 0.90 when comparing the two groups
i'll end this set of experiments by
saying that anti-stars cov2 ig responses
were
robust in our icu patients that the s1
protein the spike protein
and the receptor binding domain protein
were all useful for classifying sarco v2
status early after icu admission
the nucleocapsid protein was also useful
just not quite as effective as the other
three
and that the in vitrogen procardoplex
coronavirus ig panel was sensitive and
specific
for sars cov2 infection in icu patients
overall i'll end this this webinar with
the following conclusions
sars kobe 2 infection elicits a unique
clinical and biochemical signature
the transcriptional metabolomic and
proteomic profiling
of sars kobe 2 affected subjects
provides critical information on disease
pathology as well as identification of
relevant
biomarkers and therapeutic targets
and that sars kobe two infected subjects
exhibited robust serological subtype
responses
including coronavirus selective igg
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you doug for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask question box
located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
okay let's go ahead and get started all
right doug your first question
is your time course data showed a 100
separation between covered positive and
negative patients
by day three using the multiplex
does the multiplex assay provide greater
co
confidence of classification of patient
status
than a single elisa serology test
right if you recall the data there were
three
antigens that had an area under the
curve of one hundred percent
uh by day three um that tells me that
any one
of these uh antigens could be an
assay on an elisa and it would work fine
but we only looked at critically ill
patients and so the possibility that a
milder
disease or a patient is asymptomatic
they may not have the same viral load
they may not have the serological
response
as robust as in the critically ill
patients and in that that particular
case
i would think that a multiplex type of
approach looking at more than
one antigen would be the way to go
okay and why do you covet patients have
such a very disease
course from asymptomatic to critical icu
so that's that's one of the golden
questions that we're trying to answer
uh i think it's going to be
multifactorial it's going to be
they're going to be lots of factors
involved no doubt but
i would suggest that viral load plays a
big role
the bigger the viral load the more
cytotoxic t
cell infiltration the more enzymes
released such as granzyme b
the more host cell destruction and
tissue remodeling
and based on everything we've looked at
and all the molecules are involved it
seems like
certainly macrophage and phagocytic
acidic activity and so forth are very
important
and i think if you look at the trend in
in total
it's probably related to viral load and
cell infiltration causing tissue damage
okay and this next user says thank you
for a superb
comprehensive presentation
why do you think you did not see
statistically significant
difference in the il-6 between
icu and non-icu patients
whereas several earlier studies did
demonstrate
significant elevation
so if you look at the il-6 data as a
whole what has come out
you see that in a number of studies
there's no difference in il-6
whether you compare it to uh other
other icu patients or to milder patients
in some cases you see a mild
milder elevation some of the studies
have only compared
healthy controls to sick cova patients
and of course there's an elevation under
those circumstances
and a lot of studies only looked at one
or two time points
that's why i'll just refer you back to
our one letter that we sent into
critical care explorations
where we i think when we think of any of
cytokines and anti-cytokine therapy
we have to be looking uh at at multiple
populations they have to be well matched
and some of the studies were not well
matched where the covid patients
were not very sick relative to the other
icu patients they were compared to
so i think we have to have well-matched
uh patient populations number one
uh number two we have to do multiple
time points and and time courses with
these cytokines making sure we're not
missing anything
and i think the third thing is how we do
the experiments so
for example when we did our multiplex
measurements every plate we used had
pretty much equal amounts of different
patients on
on the plates at the same time so i'm
confident that when we see
an elevation or we don't see it it's not
related to the experimental technique or
the platforms
that are being used and that also
creates a little bit of variability
ultimately if you go back in data
you know we've looked at il-6 for quite
some time in septic patients and il-6
inhibitors
have always failed and if you go
go look at the data you will see that
ards patients that are quite sick
will have 20 30 40 fold higher levels
of il-6 relative to what we're seeing in
covet
so i think the overall
landscape is telling us that il-6 is
probably
not the target we should be looking at
and in fact just recently i think there
was
four randomized control trials each with
certain positive aspects or negative
aspects but they have also
failed to show much of an improvement
with il-6 inhibitors
so i think we we have to take another
look at this and refocus
and i would suggest tnf based on what
we've seen with a 10-fold persistent
increase
with well-matched patients looking over
a time course
however i'll also admit that other
studies
which suffered from fewer time points
and not well-matched patients
did not see the elevation that we saw
but i would think tnf would be a better
place to to to target
okay great thank you the next question
how is viral load determined and does
the method
vary at different stages of disease
that's a great question and it's not
something that i have looked at
personally i think some people have used
pcr measurements
um other people have used antigen
antigen measurements but at the end of
the day
it's very difficult to do because a
nasal swab
may be at any given point in time may be
good for the nasal cavity it may not
really reflect
the viral load in the lung um we can
look at the creatinine levels
uh seem to have some sort of correlation
with acute
acute kidney injury which would suggest
that virus has gotten into the
into the proximal tubules in the kidney
and cause some
some problems there that's related to
viral infection of of those
that particular cell type but it's a
difficult thing to look at accurately
okay would the choice of therapy depend
on initial viral load so would therapy
be modified if the result does not
quickly change
viral burden uh
it's a again it's a good question i i
think though until we can accurately
determine viral load
across large populations um it's a
little bit of a new point
instead i think we have to look at the
patients themselves see how quickly
they're progressing
see how quickly they have or multi-organ
involvement
in particular i would look at changes in
the lung and
changes in renal renal function as well
okay thank you um next question it has
been observed that critically ill
patients have high incidences
of blood clotting in multiple organ
systems
do you think clots are originating at
the site of infection
and transversing the body or does the
dysregulated immune
response lead to widespread blood
clotting
i i would suggest it's widespread blood
clotting i
i would suggest that um it's it's
certainly more intense in the pulmonary
vasculature
likely because of the in the the intense
t cell and neutrophil invasion and the
local release of enzymes
that are likely activating the
endothelium and
degrading the glycocalyx but but
certainly
all of those mediators are are going to
to travel to other spots in the body
and i think that's probably underlying
some of the the more widespread uh
phenomena that we're seeing
okay and have you or will you be
investigating profiles in patients with
acute versus long coven
well we we've got a number
of uh studies on the go and studies that
are proposed
frankly the biggest problem we're having
in london ontario canada and in many of
the canadian sites is we do not have
many copied patients
that are that are being admitted to
hospital and or
and or to the intensive care unit likely
related to
the public health measures that have
been instituted
okay next question oh this says
amazing presentation doug more of a
generic question
today we got word that pfizer has put
out a vaccine that is 90
effective this seems too fast from a
clinical perspective to be ready
i'm curious what your view is on this
going forward
well i'm not a vaccine expert so i don't
think
i can really offer much on that
particular question i think we have to
sit back
we see have to see how well
the vaccines work over the long period
and what their adverse
profiles are uh you
and i you know it's just gonna be a
matter of time till these things play
out
okay all right let's see we've got time
for a few more questions
um how reliable do you think the
serological test
against the cars stars kobe to binding
domain
or spikes protein are given
how how new many are on the market how
many new
how many are on the market how many new
ones are on the market does that make
sense sorry this came in a little bit
different
yeah i think that i think the question
is is they're coming on the market quite
quickly and there's quite a few of them
um it's it's really difficult to say
because it a lot of these
serological tests there's not a lot of
information that that comes with them
to even know what what they're actually
targeting um
so you know instead i i i it's
yeah it's really it it's really hard to
say for that reason
alone uh i i think what i've what i've
looked at so far with dbc with thermal
fissure
and also uh with our hospital pathology
department
uh we've investigated a number of kids
some of which are health canada
regulated some which are not
um there's a a wide variety but the the
good news is
uh the pattern that i'm seeing is that
they're getting better
and better and better all the time so i
think that's the good news
um the difficulty in answering your
question is is is knowing what the
targets are that a lot of these kids are
actually
looking at
all right thank you we've got time for a
couple more questions here
do you um sorry you made the provocative
statement
that treatment of active covenanting
disease
with convalescent plasma may be
redundant given the robust antibody
response
based on one eliza type of test might it
be
necessary to identify the relevant
antibodies such
as the receptor binding domain which is
the neutralizing portion of antibodies
instead of looking into total titer
against only one antigen
would the broader view enabled by
multiplexing approach
give more differentiated information
information um so i it was a provocative
statement
um however i'm and i'm
i'm using or i'm making that statement
based on not only
our studies but having the benefit of
knowing uh what's what else is going on
with the other studies so for example
the dutch study that i referenced
um showed that the vast majority of
patients
um that they developed neutralizing
antibodies so we know that
uh and they were stopped i think that
study was stopped after about 86
patients and a one-to-one randomization
so there is no obvious benefit to
complex and plasma therapy
and we know that there is a good
intrinsic response in the icu patients
we also saw heard me in our icu patients
very robust responses
i cannot say definitively that all the
the responses we saw were all
neutralizing
uh however when i look at the literature
as a whole uh
and this particular dutch study as well
as a few other studies which have been
ended early
um i think it's safe to say that there
there may be
some redundancy and the risk of course
with convalescent plasma therapy
is you may set off the innate system all
over again
um so we have to be a little bit careful
with tread lightly with those types of
of
of uh of therapies but the
the the questions right on the money we
need to know what's neutralizing
okay do you think haemo familia
hemophilia patients have more chances to
survive if they get the virus
i really can't answer that question
because i simply don't have
adequate knowledge of hemophilia
patients i'm afraid to say
certainly i see them and i work with
them but in terms of the disease
spectrum
uh and and some of the some of the
physiological and pathophysiological
uh aspects that they share but i'm
afraid i can't really answer that
okay did you also look into
immunity to the common cold
coronaviruses
included in luminex multiplex assay
to check if there is a correlation
between
pre-existing immunity to common cold
coronaviruses
and an earlier stars kobe 2 immune
response onset
right so i think the question there is
can the immune system be primed
by earlier uh infections with the more
common coronaviruses that
that caused the the more common cold and
uh all i can say is with the multiplex
uh that we
work that we did um we did look at a
number of other human coronaviruses
and they were all negative to suggest
there was there was not
a serological response that was present
in those patients
already with the exception of the
the sars kobe had a very mild response
which increased over time and
it may be possible that sars covi2
infection
may have acted caused some sort of
reactivation of that
virus of course is also possible there
may be some cross reactivity
uh but in in general there's no evidence
uh from our experiments and
and i don't know of any evidence uh
that's been presented to suggest that
uh the immune response is primed or or
better off by a previous coronavirus
common cold infection
all right we've got time for one last
question here
it has been many years since sars kobe
won
it has the same mechanism of cell entry
why did we not have a better
understanding of treatment plans
yeah and i a difficult question to
answer it's a good point uh
what's the what's the difference between
one and two and
uh you know if we could answer that
question alone it may really help direct
our
our therapies on the on number two
um it does enter it does have a lot of
similar properties
but you certainly didn't get the same
immune reaction and the same
tissue infiltration and i don't know why
that is
well thank you doug for your informative
um presentation
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go today
i think i'll just say thank you to
thermal fisher for sponsoring this
webinar
and my email address is what's on the
slides and i'm i'm happy to answer any
further questions in the future or if
anyone has any any interest in our work
or provisional patents
thank you we'd also like to thank
labyrius and our sponsor thermofisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
like doug mentioned any questions we did
not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand and labrets will
alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live
event until next time take care goodbye
you